bonjour monsieur son merci d'être avec
nous aujourd'hui sur rt france alors on
parle 1 depuis ce matin deux de ces
célébrations à moscou pour célébrer le 9
mai justement que représente le 9 mai
pour pour les russes mais je crois que
c'est un jour fondamental pour les
russes puisque la la russie et les
peuples de l'ancienne union soviétique
ont payé le plus lourd tribut à la
seconde guerre mondiale 1 27 million de
membres
causée par par la brutalité de la guerre
qui avait été lancée par l'allemagne
nazie 13 millions de soldats 14 millions
de ces villes et puis vu d'europe de
l'ouest ont l'eau on oublie trop souvent
la plus elle l'armée rouge qui a libéré
l'europe du nazisme en subissant le gros
de la tacc militaire et en écrasant ce
qui était en 1941 la plus la plus
terrible armée du monde à savoir l'armée
nazie
donc je crois que c'est quelque chose
d'absolument fondamentale et on ne peut
que regretter que l'europe de l'ouest
sous-estiment la contribution russe et
soviétique de l'époque à la victoire
militaire contre le nazisme
en quoi justement où l'europe de l'ouest
sous estiment l'impact qu'a eu une
l'armée rouge dans dans la victoire
finale je me rappelle une discussion
avec un vétéran de l'armée rouge
un officier soviétique russe qui m'avait
dit s'intéressant votre débarquement en
normandie
finalement c'est une bataille vue de vue
de l'est une petite bataille delà de la
deuxième guerre mondiale et je crois
qu'il y à chaque année au mois de juin
une une exagération dans l'importance du
front du front occidental alors que
l'essentiel se passait se passait à
l'aise je rappelle simplement un chiffre
dans la dernière bataille la bataille de
berlin l'armée rouge a encore perdu
300000 morts
c'est absolument absolument considérable
et sa montre
d'une part la brutalité avec laquelle
l'armée allemande a combattu et d'autre
part l'effort qu'il a fallu faire le
sacrifice que fallu faire est d'ailleurs
un des grands un des grands déficit de
la la réconciliation européenne
c'est l'absence de geste après la
réunification de l'allemagne vis-à-vis
de la russie comme il y en avait eu
vis-à-vis de la france et de la pologne
vous évoquiez tout à l'heure le rôle de
l'armée rouge dans la libération de
toute cette europe de l'efs vous évoquez
à l'instant cette bataille de berlin est
ce que vous pouvez justement à nous
rappeler le contexte de cette bataille
de berlin dans quel contexte elle a eu
lieu à combien de temps à la durée
là la dernière offensive donc je
rappelle la porte effectivement pour
tout le monde les les les dates là
l'offensive allemande contre l'union
soviétique commence en juin 41
il y à un tournant après la bataille de
stalingrad au début de l'année 1943
mais ensuite il faut encore plus plus de
deux ans pour que l'armée rouge
réussissent à reconquérir les
territoires occupés et ensuite aille
jusqu'à berlin pour pour pour libérer
l'europe et est donc cette cette
dernière bataille est là elle a commencé
environ six semaines avant le avant la
capitulation et elle a été absolument
absolument terrible parce que les
soldats allemands alors même qu'ils
étaient en recul l'ecl ils avaient peur
effectivement des représailles de
l'armée rouge ont combattu m'ont
combattu pied à pied et c'était une
question aussi pour staline évidemment
de de conc'air berlin il y avait une
question de prestige du point de vue de
l'armée rouge tout à l'heure j'ai évoqué
la date du 9 mai pour ces célébrations
alors qu'en france ou ailleurs en europe
on a plutôt tendance à affecter à la
victoire le
est-ce que vous pouvez justement nous
rappeler le contexte de la signature de
l'acte de capitulation à berlin si vous
voulez des déjà à l'époque il est
certain que les les alliés se
occidentaux et soviétiques se
regardaient en chiens de faïence s'était
pas encore la guerre froide mais il y
avait de la méfiance mutuelle
mais il n'y a pas eu effectivement d'
acte de capitulation unique
d'où ce décalage horaire entre ce qui
s'est passé ce qui s'est passé le 8 mai
sur le territoire français ce qui s'est
passé ce qui s'est passé le 9 mai pour
la capitulation du côté soviétique
merci beaucoup et beau russe on va voir
était avec nous ce matin sur les
antennes darty france rappelle que vous
êtes historien et spécialiste de la
seconde guerre mondiale